so this is hot to the touch and yeah
this was the one I saw the floor but in
case you know I remember uh it actually
leads off exactly where it left off
which actually I think I missed that
part when I first saw it where it's
literally right after the slap and last
episode was the ending of the third
season right yes I'm almost wondering I
guess it's unlikely but I'm almost
wondering if they left that as like the
cliffhanger and then they want to see
how the character went over and like if
you went over well it's like okay let's
keep that story going well that's
interesting
what we realized was a cliffhanger until
we cause a lot of those to work that way
where it's like are they gonna continue
that it's like nope and then I come back
like eight episodes later but others are
like nothing we're gonna take off in
second um so if Fingal's after is just
really obsessed and chases after her I
have to find some way to you know get in
contact with her because she's you know
pretty pissed off that she thinks that
he turned her down constantly before
what really was a Jake and so the gold
is junkyard to make this suit to get
closer to their house don't listen
yeah that's why neptr was hiding there
which is great now that see makes sense
I just sort of assumed as part of like a
joke before or something but yeah now
it's like really funny yeah it also
shows at least to like me how much they
don't give a shit about neptr because
you think about BMO they treat BMO like
he's a member of the family neptr who
can forget I didn't feel kind of bad
that they forgot about it not really cuz
in a matter of seconds they're like okay
let's get back to doing over noon okay
he clearly doesn't care that there's
like her right now uh now I'll close my
eyes
you know we got this to focus on but
yeah and so they build this suit Flame
Princess just go on the warpath sort of
destroying this town and everything Finn
Collins in town says you know I want to
be with you and at first she thinks that
you know maybe this can work but then
she realizes that they're literally
opposites which Fitness like but that
could be good and she says no because
you know I'm fire and you're made of
water he's a water elemental because he
creates water all the time no no I don't
but the funny thing is that we think
she's made of fire and it's we are made
of water so that kind of makes sense I
that's actually I think very clever uh
and to a point where he says you know
she says you'd risk you know you dream
it defy nature yeah you know to be with
me and he says you know I at least try
it and really great scene they tried to
hug and obviously she burns him and he
pushes her away and it's just one of
those things where it's it's it's kinda
hard to actually see I don't think he
pushed her away he was he was crying he
started crying tears because it hurt and
when his tear hit her she was
convertible pushing each other away
oh is that oh okay I think it was kind
of a bolt there something at the same
time because they're both getting hurt
by the hug this is how they hurt a each
other yeah so but I mean bottom line she
especially sees it's not gonna work like
you know they can the closer they get
the more they hurt each other she even
says we're going to keep hurting each
other and you know I was just in my head
like the Carpenters song it's called
learning each other look it up
mata and he slept just feeling hurt and
and J&J comes up
everyone's dead bag there's rotted
corpses everywhere routes ten really oh
yeah it just love hurts that's the end
of this episode
yeah it's having seen it before and now
seeing it in context uh it was still
really good um you know she reminds me a
lot of a I'm sure he's based this on
better stuff she reminds me a lot of a
Tim Burton character just well those
people like she can't touch anything
without destroying it you know Caesar
Edward Scissorhands is sure like when he
used to do a lot of these illustrations
and write these little short stories and
stuff like that you know he sort of do
these characters they have like one
giant flaw that would like destroy
everything to come in contact with and
they'd be left alone and of course
they'd be brooding and stuff um and she
reminds me a bit of them like everything
she touches you know he is set ablaze I
like the idea that when she said
something on fire and people try to
stomp it out that hurts her I think
that's really cool that's really
creative and yeah I mean it's a fun care
that you can have a lot of fun drama
with you know in terms of fly yards she
clearly likes to destroy things but
she's also for love but everything she
touched gets destroyed and it's a is a
real meaty character to have fun with so
yes just a sound episode I even like to
I even like nectar nectar nectar sorry
never-ending-pie-throwing robot so that
even he was funny in it which I did
dislike it before but just he never did
much for me but this episode I thought
he was like especially funny so uh yeah
but you Jory I liked it I think it's
getting late and I've lost my mind cuz
like I see Flame Princess and like I
just even from the previous
to this episode the way she acts and
everything it's like she's one of those
crazy you know like those psycho chicks
you know like I hate you why are you
doing this to me like those psycho
girlfriends that likes to stalk you it's
no offense because I do love her I love
her character and it's no offense I
don't know why but I feel like she makes
that type of character almost
sympathetic seeing the crazy from the
crazy side instead of the interesting
thing in this one is that in a sense
Fitness kind of the crazy one cuz he's
chasing after her even though clearly I
mean he knows if he touches her he'll
get hurt and the closer he gets you know
that they'll hurt one another um you
know but he's still dead he wanted you
know he's almost more the start when
she's trying to get away from him
he's a lovesick in a way I think it's
really cute I don't think that she's
stalking him I think she I yeah I think
she's again and I don't know why I'm
doing this it's like she's had this
problem before like she's so damaged
with why you why are you doing things
she's so suspicious that's why was she
kept in there laughter she's so very
suspicious see you know no don't
describe up something that you guys seem
to remember when you first meet her
where is she she was locked up in the
lantern thing and when she finished it
finally see her what's she doing when
they finally catch up with her with the
birds he's spoken wonder what's she
doing mister she's just trying to
understand what's going on with the
flashy touches the water she learns that
that hurts yeah what does that kind of
say about how she's been brought up I'll
guess
I think it's more along those lines of
her not really knowing what's going on
in the world not really understanding
how everything is and her trying to deal
with it she wants to make her own fire
Kingdom she's not I don't think she's
like I'm gonna kill everyone in the
world that was that was I have to say
that was something I did realize right
away she got out and she could have just
gotten straight back home because you
know forget you Finn you're mean and
horrible you know but no she's just
wandering and she's like I'll make my
own yeah her own fire Kingdom she has no
desire to go back home it's like she
doesn't even it's not even a thought so
I don't think she's the crazy stalker
bitch crazy psycho stalkers that would
you know stock you and watch it
its way for her like what like 900 never
Medlin you seriously go to school
tomorrow
later okay we don't know for me I like
that she's more innocent than anything
else
she has all this power she has all this
rage pent up inside of her probably
daddy issues but when you break it down
and you see her she's just very innocent
she doesn't know what's going on and
when Finn says oh okay and I feel like
I'm gonna use that from now on when I go
a little cuckoo bird but yeah when one
part today did like with the machines
that were made and how unfinished at the
rainbow oh you like a tattoo if you
notice up here to peace symbol as well
and I love the design of those but then
when fins like no like nectar turns the
foam cannon on Flame Princess and there
she is on the ground like looking
pitiful like oh my god what's going on
he's like no then he's like finally
enough for the Yanks here he rips it
down destroying part of nectar I was
like oh my god you killed dr. I don't
know my god he's fine
darn it I mean you see like the hmm I
like that it's it's something new you
know a one-credit
sound strange but to the the kid who
plays finding this one the last one uh
you know it's not like he had to give
these really big monologues or anything
these big emotional monologues but he
did there's a couple times where he
really had to scream and he really need
to be emotional and it's a little
tougher than you think it's hard to do
that without sounding corny yeah silly
and especially on adventure time where
so many characters scream in so many
different funny ways and when he
screamed both in this episode the last
one it sounded romantic it felt like oh
this kid is pissed you know he's really
he's really into this moment so yeah
just kudos man especially with the voice
kind of changing - I mean that's it's
hard to do all those things at once you
know to scream on the show everybody
screams make it dramatic and do it while
your voice is breaking I mean that's
really impressive
so will you help me a thing that just
takes advantage of the fact that Jake
and I really love so yet still still
solid character and good I this is one
where I would like to see where they go
with it I mean do the I I can't see them
just cutting it off there and maybe they
do but I can't see them just cutting it
off and I think they could have more fun
um there's too much of an enjoyable
tragedy to it do you know it's like it
is just so tragic like you said there is
service young innocent fat has a temper
but you understand why yeah you know I
mean if you couldn't touch everything
anything you touch was destroyed
everyone fear you I mean you would get
it yeah and if she's Finn's age remember
she's 13 yeah she's gotta be 30 that's a
funny how many reasonable 13-year olds
are out there yeah I mean so all these
things are going on yeah everyone
tearing them look different
I like to say I like to say I did not
but you know she's watching while you're
looking at her see I knew that God my
wife is 13 Oh in the spirit I don't know
that makes it better what things about
Mary I imagine it